microsoft trains a model that's three
times as large as gpt-3 nvidia releases
the third iteration of their stylegan
model and deepmind goes hard on ml for
biology welcome to ml news
you might have already heard this but
weights and biases has just raised a
series c round at the valuation of 1
billion us dollars and is now officially
a unicorn congratulations to weights and
bias is one of the absolute top products
in the market and i'm not just saying
this out of the goodness of my heart
they actually pay me to say this so
thank you so much to ways and biases for
sponsoring this video now how might this
benefit you imagine weights and biases
they get all this cash right now they're
just going to dump this on you in form
of free product so you can expect the
weights and biases system to become more
powerful better looking faster whatever
you want and for the foreseeable future
it's probably going to be available to
you for free as it is right now
hello
yeah
[Music]
i'm not sure i can make promises against
the the nature of the universe
all right all right
yes i'll do it okay
all right so apparently the products are
going to be free forever for personal
use and academia yes
forever
so that's the beauty of startup money
it's spend first and then earn back
later so if you don't know what weights
and biases is weights and biases is a
general suite of tools for machine
learning engineers machine learning
researchers and everyone in the life
cycle of ml products it can track your
experiments it can save your models and
data sets it can monitor your runs and
it is with you from experiment all the
way to deployment it's usually in the
cloud but it can be on premise so if you
want to take part in that sweet sweet
cash inflow go to weights and biases
right now and again congratulations to
them they should absolutely pay me more
now that they have more
hello hello and welcome everyone to ml
news there's a lot to go through so
let's get going microsoft trains
megatron touring nlg 530b
how many words can you accumulate to
make a model sound really really really
big i guess we're gonna find out with
the next iteration but for this
situation this is a giant model now this
is essentially a decoder only language
model much like gpt3 yet it is quite a
bit bigger so this model has 105 layers
its hidden dimension is over 20 000 and
each layer has 128 attention hits this
new model achieves various
state-of-the-art results in zero-shot
nlp tasks and this blog post details
what it can do and more importantly how
it was trained so the training relies on
this library called deep speed by
microsoft which is a library to train
these large kinds of models split over
multiple computers when i say multiple
computers i don't mean 12 raspberry pies
in fact this training is powered by
560 dgx a100 servers that's not 560 gpus
that's 560 servers each of which has
eight a100 gpus inside of them and
everything is connected by envy link and
envy switch and super duper infiniband
so this is an absolute beast it trained
with a batch size of
1920 and achieves about 120 teraflops
per second per gpu in throughput now the
sheer scale of this is absolutely crazy
and it's questionable whether or not
humanity really wants to go this route
of scaling up in this matter but i'm
glad they did in this case noteworthy is
for example the fact that they didn't
start out with a big batch size in fact
they started with a batch size of 32 and
then gradually increased to the final
batch size another noteworthy thing is
that their training data is based on the
pile by luther ai which is an open
source data set that came out of the
efforts of replicating gpt-3 which
noteworthy has not released their
training data yet but like gpt 3 the
authors here pay close attention to the
quality of their data so even inside the
pile they sample various proportions
differently and they also add some
things from common crawl and real news
to arrive at their final data set the
article details what kind of scores the
model reaches on what kind of zero-shot
tasks if you're interested check it out
i don't know if the model will be
accessible or whether this was just an
academic exercise or whether microsoft
wants to make money with it i guess
we'll see
nvidia releases style gan 3. we've
covered this paper previously it was
called alias free generative adversarial
networks so not much has changed since
then notably you can see the comparison
of stylegan 2 which had a very hard
dependency on the position in the image
so you see the hair texture sort of
remains at the point where the image is
yet stalgan 3 has solved these issues
largely as you can see the entire
objects move around independent of their
absolute position so this gives rise to
a lot more maybe controllable maybe
realistic pictures so what's new is that
they have now released the code and the
models to go along with this and people
have already tried out a bunch of stuff
including putting these into notebooks
together with clip so thanks to the
people involved here and shepard eugenio
herrera and katherine kraussen so if you
want to try this out remember stylegan 2
is trained on specific data sets so for
example here i have taken the faces data
set you're able to enter some sort of
prompt here for clip now i just entered
the prompt eagle because i didn't know
what was going to happen so here's the
start and let's see what happens okay
yep
yep ah
all right
i guess eagle means i'll just slowly
disappear
but people have come up with quite cool
stuff here give it a try and see what
happens
here's an interesting paper by yuval
kirstein patrick lewis sebastian riedel
and omar levy called a few more examples
maybe worth billions of parameters they
analyze different nlp tasks and they
discover that for some tasks collecting
a few labeled examples will in fact
increase the performance of the model in
a very drastic way compared to something
like a zero shot performance now this is
not the case for all models though which
is the interesting part so for example
if you take something like open question
answering which is where the model has
to recall information or go look for
information then increasing the number
of examples doesn't necessarily mean
that the model gets better however just
scaling up the model pre-training it on
more data that is worth a lot but if you
go to something like extractive question
answering where you don't have to recall
anything in fact you're given the
wikipedia article usually where the
answer is contained somewhere and all
you need to do is find the answer then a
few more labeled examples are actually
just as good as scaling the model up to
drastic degrees so the authors
hypothesize that in something like open
question answering it's really about how
much of pre-training you have which
means how much stuff is stored in your
weights whereas for extractive question
answering it's much more how can you map
the question that you're given two
specific words in the article so the
model can learn a lot even from very
very simple and few examples so this
might be a thing to consider if you're
in an area of nlp and you may not have a
lot of data and you ask yourself should
i spend the money to get more training
examples well i guess it depends on the
task
[Music]
another interesting paper is something
something strike through patches are all
you need
emoji under review at iclear2020
so the first question is have paper
titles gone too far so this is an
absolute meme paper but the actual
contents are really nice essentially the
paper does a hybrid architectures
between the vision transformers and the
mlp mixers they hypothesize that at
least in part what makes vision
transformers good are the fact that they
operate on patches and not necessarily
the transformer architecture by
themselves so they propose an
architecture where you put the image
into patches but then it's just a mix
between depth-wise convolution and
point-wise convolution much like the
idea of mlp mixer where you mix the
dimensions and then mix the locations
repeatedly with this they're able to
outperform the other two models and most
importantly this is to the best of their
knowledge the first model that achieves
the elusive goal of having eighty
percent plus imagine at top one accuracy
while also fitting into a tweet our
field is just memes now
and another paper that piqued my
interest vector quantized image modeling
with improved vq gan this is an
iteration on vqgan involving vision
transformers funnily enough after the
last paper so they go with a two-stage
approach where in the first stage they
use a transformer encoder and decoder
and in between a quantization layer now
quantization has been really successful
in recent months so it's not surprising
that people make strides when
introducing quantizations into new
places this then is paired with an auto
regressive transformer that takes in the
encoded codebook vectors or indices
thereof and essentially learns a
language model over these so you're
taking a picture you encode it into
latent space and then in the latent
space you describe it as a sequence of
code book vectors and that sequence is
essentially a language by itself and on
this language you can train an
autoregressive transformer so now when
you want to sample a new image you can
simply go to your transformer you can
let it sample a sequence of these code
book vectors as they would appear in the
data set you can use the transformer
decoder to decode it and there you get a
new image now the images of this model
look really nice and that is actually my
problem the images almost look too
perfect they look super smooth they look
absolutely crisp and just these images
right here they seem so clean that
they're not even real anymore like i
would expect these pictures on the front
of like a glossy magazine a time
magazine cover a national geographic
cover or something like this not just
pictures taken by some person somewhere
live science writes william shatner a i
we'll chat with you about the star trek
actor's life now this article is
essentially about a product called story
file a story file looks to be quite a
cool product what they do is they will
sit you down and film you and ask you
various questions about your life that
people may ask now you just sit there
and you just answer these questions i
guess this is gonna take quite a long
time but once you have this compiled
it's sort of like an faq about your life
and then what they do is they provide
you with this text interface or with a
speech interface where you can now ask a
question so what makes this different to
a regular faq is simply that you ask a
question and then it finds the closest
match in the faq list and gives you that
answer as pre-recorded and then there's
also one time where shatner says i can't
make any sense of that and that's what
happens when you answer any other
question that it can't map so how much
of this is really ai not sure but it's
definitely good that they put ai in
quotes when they titled the article
google ai writes about finding complex
metal oxides for technology advancement
this blog post is a pretty cool report
about research that has been done in
finding new materials material science
is notoriously difficult because
essentially we have no clue what happens
if we mix two things together that no
one has mixed together before and given
the amount of things there are to mix
most things haven't been mixed before
the authors here developed a new method
of using an inkjet printer to
essentially print mixtures in various
dosages into lines on a piece of i don't
know cardboard paper something like this
these are plates and you print out these
metal oxide mixtures in lines in various
mixtures components or fractions then
you bake them and then you use optical
analysis to try to assess their
properties now not all properties are
accessible via optical analysis but you
can use machine learning to try to
suggest to you interesting compounds
that you might want to look further at
so out of the giant amount of possible
combinatorical possibilities to mix they
have come down to just very few that
they needed to test further so this is
very much like drug discovery where also
machine learning is now helping to
suggest new compounds that might be
interesting to look at so in the end
they found 51 oxide systems with
interesting behavior only one of them
had previously been experimentally
validated so all in all pretty cool if
you're into material science give this
article definitely a read
next up techcrunch writes gretel ai
raises 50 million us dollars for a
platform that lets engineers build and
use synthetic data sets to ensure the
privacy of their actual data gradle ai
is a company that focuses on data
privacy on how can we make ml work in
sensitive settings how do we not leak
private data and so on so one of their
services is they let you abstract your
data such that your ml algorithms can
still train but they will train on
synthetic data that is guaranteed to be
privacy protected now just conceptually
this is a bit more challenging than it
just might seem like any information you
pull out of data is potentially related
to the privacy of the data where it
comes from even synthetic data even with
various guarantees as long as
information is transmitted it seems like
there might be a risk but these people
are the experts so i'm not gonna claim
anything here and it looks like their
tools are useful in a wide variety of
applications now what i love is their
website where they have this demo called
accelerate your tasks and here is the
timeline that without gretel you have to
do oh no you have an idea you need to go
ask your boss oh you need to copy
sensitive data no you have to do all
these things at once and then with
gretel wait wait watch that click here
wow
idea integrate gretel instantly
synthesize or anonymize data
innovate
in any way there's a blog post that goes
along with the 50 million new funding
about why privacy by design matters more
than ever if you're interested give it a
read and i need to leave
i got kicked up from my other studio um
it's not technically my studio this is
gonna be resolved pretty soon you'll see
there's gonna be a new studio it's gonna
be epic where were we oh yes deepmind
has released two new works one is here
on bioarchive and one is a blog post by
themselves though there's a paper to go
along with this as well the first paper
is called protein complex prediction
with alpha fold multimer and this is a
specifically crafted version of alpha
fall to predict the folding of protein
complexes so while the original alpha
fold was made to predict how a protein
folds from its original chain of amino
acids into its final 3d structure the
alpha fold multimer model handles cases
where there's not just one chain of
amino acids involved multiple chains
will fold up to create what's called a
protein complex and these are
notoriously even harder to predict
and these are notoriously even harder to
predict than just single protein so
alpha fold multimer contains various
improvements that make predicting
protein complexes a lot more accurate
and improves not only over bass lines
but also over the original alpha fold
the second one is called predicting gene
expression with a i and here we move
from the land of proteins to the world
of genes so in your cells you have dna
and dna is essentially a long strand of
information and from this information
the amino acid chains that make up the
proteins are read off and translated and
transcribed now it is really important
to know which parts of the dna are read
and also how often they are read and
translated various things on the dna can
influence how different regions are read
off for example if one part of the dna
is coding for a protein that region is
generally called a gene then whether or
not that gene is actually read off and
how much it can be influenced by factors
such as how tightly the dna is wound
around proteins called histones there
are also various methyl modifications of
the dna and lastly and this might be the
most complex thing there can be what are
called promoter and inhibitor sequences
that are in front of the gene that
influence that gene and these can be
really far away so imagine a really long
text and whatever is happening in here
in the text is influenced by like a
single word or two words that come way
way way before it's like an uber german
sentence so how better to handle this
than throw a giant transformer at the
problem and this is what deepmind did
right here with the giant transformer
trained on the dna they can predict gene
expression better than bass lines and
this will improve our understanding and
prediction of what various modifications
to the dna will do so if there is some
sort of a variant then gene expressions
can be predicted without having to
necessarily test it beforehand very cool
give it a read
kunihiko fukushima has won the bauer
award for achievement in science for
work on the neo-cognitron possibly the
earliest implementation of what would
now be called a convolutional neural
network so fukushima's pioneering work
is being prized with an award and some
prize money and none other than jurgen
schmidt huber has publicly released a
youtube video to honor kuniko fukushima
for this work and for the reception of
the award now schmidthuber actually has
opened a youtube channel as far as i can
tell just for this video or at least
that might be the first one now is
jurgen going to join the ranks of us ml
youtubers it would be amazing i mean
this is de facto reaction content so
he's already halfway there now schmidt
hoover gives a glowing review of the
work of fukushima and what the
influences of that work were and he
generally seems to be pretty pleased
with kuniku receiving this award though
about halfway through the speech he
starts to switch fro away from work of
fukushima to work of funnily enough
his own labs now i think the story arc
he had in mind was to sort of give an
overview of what fukushima had done and
then set this in relation to what is
happening today but what is happening
today is entirely framed in works of
schmidt uber's lab now of course he's
giving this speech so fair enough but
with the exception of damn net which is
a convolutional neural network that is
coming from his labs and a year before
alexnet won several competitions in
computer vision the rest of the talk is
essentially
disconnected from fukushima's work
together talking about lstms and how
it's one of the most successful papers
of all times talking about how
transformers were invented in the 90s by
his labs more lstms and a brief
discussion on dan net then going into
how highway networks are essentially a
precursor to resnets and at the end
circling back to fukushima's work so
it's essentially congratulations his
work was awesome also my work is awesome
also congratulations his work is awesome
now if you're interested the entire
speech is available on youtube and we of
course welcome jurgen to the circle of
ml youtubers
okay some helpful stuff for this week
bayer is a benchmark for zero shot
evaluation of information retrieval
models this is available on github and
it has various data sets and benchmarks
for information retrieval the bayesian
optimization book by rowan garnett is
out online it will remain free online
but this version is a sort of a
pre-print and i think comments are very
welcome so if you're into bayesian
optimization or looking to get into it
this is a nice resource imagineer by
nvidia is a pie torch library for gans
that now also includes the famous gan
craft so if you've always wondered what
your minecraft worlds look like if they
were real places this might be the place
to go
mosaic is a new ml startup that came out
of stealth mode and presents itself as
making ml training efficient notably
they came up with two products one is
this experiment explorer which pays
special attention to not only your
accuracy and your loss curves but also
the cost and the efficiency at which
your experiments run so for a given
baseline you can find out what is the
cheapest way to reach the same accuracy
what is the highest quality that you can
achieve while keeping the same speed
what if i want the same cost and so on
the other product is the composer which
is supposedly a library to make training
uh neural networks more reproducible so
you can drop in various extra algorithms
such as learning rate schedules or
squeeze excite layers and so on now do
we really need another neural network
library and how modular is all of this
really i guess we'll see how this
develops to me neural network training
is seems to be still intricate enough
that libraries are most useful when they
give you nice primitives that you can
plug together instead of ticking a
couple of checkboxes like here i guess
it's going to be pretty hard for them to
make all of this work together on the
other hand it's going to be i guess kind
of easy for something like weights and
biases to also include a cost measure of
training and be a real competitor to
mosaic here so i get it these people
make this their primary mission but i
think it's still going to be a
hard-fought battle over the ml tooling
space i'm excited to see what happens
tech explorer writes germany unveils its
first self-driving train now
self-driving trains have been used in
things like airports and so on but this
is the first self-driving train in
germany that runs alongside other trains
on the same tracks so the report here is
actually pretty funny in that it says
these self-driving trains are more
punctual and energy efficient than
traditional trains they offer a more
reliable service they transport up to 30
more passengers and significantly
improve punctuality and save more than
30 of energy now what they're actually
saying is that german people suck at
running trains
simply replacing human drivers
coordinators schedulers and so on with
machines makes such a difference that's
on you germans that's not on the
machines
the new york post writes pentagon's
first software chief quit because china
has already won global tech war pretty
strong statement i have to say so
apparently he told the financial times
there's good reason to be angry at the
us for falling behind we have no
competing fighting chance against china
in 15 to 20 years right now it's a done
deal it's already over in my opinion he
claimed that the us like beijing should
have prioritized artificial intelligence
machine learning and cyber capabilities
over traditional military spending like
building new fighter jets now this is a
stance one can take cyber security and
cyber warfare are important topics but
the article gets a bit weirder he
attacked google for not working on ai
with the us defense department while
chinese companies are obliged to work
with beijing the us also wasting time
debating the ethics of ai while china
makes massive investments and issues
such concerns he said well here is how
it works u.s companies and governments
and military discuss ai ethics to please
one particular loud annoying part of the
us public mirroring that chinese
companies government and military also
discuss ai ethics to please a very loud
part of the us public i'm not sure how
serious we should take these warnings
right here it is of course an
interesting question on how much one
should balance the very real concerns of
ai ethics with the fact that somewhere
else in the world someone might care
just a little bit less about that and
then overpower you in 10 20 years
lastly deepmind becomes profitable so
apparently deepmind is now profitable
for the first time whilst it has been
hemorrhaging money in the past few years
now the article by uh tech talks here
details how this is exactly happening
deepmind doesn't have any customers by
itself it's only customer essentially is
alphabet so the parent company is the
only customer which means that deepmind
can essentially set any price they want
and the customer is going to pay it so
deepmind going into the green might be
more an accounting trick than anything
else probably the whole alphabet
construct needed to save some taxes and
that was the most optimal way to do it
the article goes into more detail on how
hard and expensive it is to really do
reinforcement learning in the real world
and also the strategy deepmind pursues
where they pay a lot of money to acquire
the world's top talent now that being
said we have recently more and more seen
deep mind venture into solving actual
real world problems with things like
alpha fall for protein folding
prediction and weather now casting it
seems like slowly it might make its way
into real markets alright this was it
for this week's ml news let me know what
you think in the comments i'll see you
next time and bye bye
[Music]
you